And what does that look like, especially on the essential oil side to complement this sort of
journey and these other treatments people are undergoing? What kind of things have you used or
recommended? Well, there's numerous essential oils from good healthy peer-reviewed studies that
will, that shows that it can be beneficial for people with cancer. From a practical standpoint,
we see the use and we do testing for each individual so we don't just have a set protocol here,
everybody who does has this type of cancer, use this. We don't do that. But from a practical
standpoint, the standbys for cancer are going to be the frake and since the murder, the lemon grass,
the copiiba, the thyme, the German chamomile, oregano. Those are the typical ones we're finding some of
the aldehyde oils like cinnamon to be also effective. I think it's through a completely
different mechanism and you know, synergistically using different oils and synergistically
linking oils with different nutraceuticals have extreme beneficial effect on the body. And of course,
everybody's different. And can you define nutraceutical as well for people unfamiliar with that
term? So a nutraceutical would be the use of a vitamin or an herb in from a medicinal purpose.
So instead of a pharmaceutical, you're using it more of a natural pharmaceutical like a curcumin
or a hyacinacia or a golden seal or a vitamin C. Those are all would be considered a nutraceutical
approach. Yeah. When I love that, that synergistic approach, I mean, that's really what makes essential
oils, I think, so powerful and so amazing to incorporate into any sort of health journey. Someone's
going on is that synergistic property, adding an essential oil to, you know, the vitamins or the
therapies or whatever you're doing can can really amplify those effects in such amazing ways. Now,
you mentioned that you would sort of test the individual for certain essential oils that could
complement their therapies. What kind of testing do you do for that? Well, we do kinesiology testate
in our office. So, but as a patient who's trying to do things on their own, they can certainly
test by see their body's response to things. I caution people about just sticking to one protocol
that they might have read on the internet or something to be careful of that because everybody's
different, you know, and especially when we see people get a diagnosis of cancer, all their friends
very well-being, trying to be helpful will, you know, send them some product or some supplement or
give them information on something that their friends, odds, brothers, wife, you know, this help
their cancer. It can be so overwhelming. It can be overwhelming. Yeah. If the person actually took
all those things, it can be overwhelming to that individual's liver. So, you do have to be careful
not to take too many things. I remember anything that you absorb, your body has to detoxify.
And too much of a good thing can also be a bad thing. So, you don't want to overwhelm somebody's liver,
especially if they have cancer when we're trying to kill cancer cells and your body's going to have
to get rid of the dead tissue and such from that too. Right. Do you know much about the effects of
lemon essential oil with supporting the liver during that detoxification process? Yeah, that could
be a support. So, when we look at detox pathways from our perspective, that's where we do genetic
testing because there's specific genes that really are the drivers of all your cytochrome P450
pathways, your pond pathways, your NAT pathways. And if a person has defects on those pathways,
they're going to have a much more difficult time detoxifying what detoxifies through that pathway.
And then there's specific, so you asked about testing. We use genetic testing a lot for
recommendation of nutrition and essential oil as well because defects on specific pathways
then you want to try to support those pathways. You can't change that genetic structure that you're
born with, those defects, but you can now I know that I have this defect. I want to support that pathway.
And so we try to get real specific with the detox pathways and not used like box detox type protocols.
But there are some general things. The limiting products essential oils are good for liver detox pathways.
Typically, the cytochrome P450 pathways, if I recall.